مع تضييق الخناق الروسي على مدينه بخموت
نشر جنديون اوكراني فيديو من المدينه
بتاريخ الاول من اذار مارس يؤكد ثبات قوات
بلاده هناك بضع انفجارات وقذائف متطايره
لكننا باقون في بخموت لا احد يخطط
للانسحاب في الوقت الحالي دمار يقول
الجنود الاوكرانيون انه يذكر بمشاهد الحرب
العالميه الاولى وتكلفه الصمود في بخموت
باهظه جدا الحديث عن مئات القتلى من
الجانبين يوميا والقتال على اشده بحسب
الرئيس الاوكراني روسيا لا تحصي اعداد
الناس تستمر في ارسالهم للهجوم على
مواقعنا والقتال يحتدم كلام مشابه ياتي من
الخصم
الروسيين مؤسس مجموعه فاجنر شبه العسكريه
الذي ظهر عده مرات الى جانب قواته على
جبهه بخموت يؤكد دراوه المعارك
الالاف من مقاتلي الجيش الاوكراني بشراسه
المعارك الدمويه تشتد يوما بعد يوم
الاسابيع الاخيره اعلن بريكوجين السيطره
على عدد من البلدات المحيطه ببحمود
وبتقدمها البطيء قطعت القوات الروسيه
ثلاثا من الطرق الاربع التي تسمح
للاوكرانيين بادخال الامدادات مقاتلون
كتيبه ازوف الهجوميه الثالثه من بين
القوات الاوكرانيه التي تدافع عن المدينه
مخبوط منطقه صعبه يوجد تركيز كبير لمشاه
العدو للاستيلاء عليها لديهم هدف محدد
ويستخدمون كل مواردهم من اجل تحقيقهم
يختلف الخبراء العسكريون حول اهميه مخموت
الاستراتيجيه الا انها ستكون اول جائزه
كبرى لروسيا منذ اشهر وتفتح الطريق
للاستيلاء على اخر المراكز الحضريه
المتبقيه في منطقه دونيتسك